in calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between jollibee in the uk and the us
this is food
[Music]
in the uk jollibee serves their famous
chicken joy in six portion sizes
starting with a one piece in the u.s you
can get your chicken joy in five
different portions a one piece
with a side next up we've got a two
piece a two piece
also with the side we move to a three
piece a three piece
that comes with a side i'm so excited to
try this is my first ever taste of
jollibee fried chicken
now my first time harry oh that's good
that was really good i don't know how it
stayed so crispy the next size is up our
buck is a chicken you can get a bucket
in six
or bucket of ten buckets from the uk
jollibee come in three sizes
starting with a six piece
then from there we move up to an eight
piece bucket
and last but by no means least our
biggest portion size is a bucket of 12.
should have got a bigger plate it's
really good
[Music]
i just love chicken this is a good
[Music]
example
there's little crispy bits that fall off
your chicken gold dust
let's each weigh our six piece buckets
to see if the chicken joint in one
country is bigger than the other
it's time for some jenga
ah we have over 100 grams
more chicken i realize this is so
arbitrary the size of the meats
uh the amount of coding but it's nice to
win
regardless the chicken and jolly bee
also comes in the form of tenders in the
uk these are served in four portion
sizes
as a single tender one one piece one
piece
who's getting one chicken tender has two
tenders
there's a portion of three tenders
and finally as a portion of four
one chicken tender i've never heard of
that anywhere well
here in america we have normal portion
sizes for our chicken tenders
you get them in three pieces six pieces
i think three is not enough
but okay three pieces six pieces
ten pieces
or 16.
yeah tenders
how do you like that there's a little
bit more going on though
i like it a little bit of heat to it the
batter seems different
it has more of like the buttermilk
flavor to it i like the coating
oh garlic man always he needs ranch when
you have garlic mass
who needs garlic mayo when you have
ranch
ranch is far superior to garlic mayo no
question
oh yeah i love ranch the worthy addition
ranch is way better herbs and spices
aren't they like basically the same
thing
then we're onto some jollibee
specialties now one iconic dish is this
one
this is the jolly spaghetti now this is
a dish made of spaghetti with some
cheese
as well as a sweet style sauce which is
i think made with like banana ketchup
and some meat as well
and then it's topped with hot dog slices
in the uk this only comes as one portion
size
it's a cute size you got there harry but
here in the us we have three sizes
a regular portion our family portion
and the party portion look at this this
is supposed to be eight to ten people
it's like a lasagna look at that now
according to a friend of mine from the
philippines the pro move is to dunk the
chicken into
the spaghetti sauce so let's give that a
try cheese the cold cheese
isn't doing any favors i'll be honest
okay yeah that's actually not bad it's a
bit misleading because their spaghetti
is actually
the sauce is sweet very good yeah
together that's really good
then we're on to the burgers now
jollibee is famous for its young burgers
which is a beef burger with its
signature burger sauce
in the uk these come as either a single
or as a double over here in the u.s you
can get the classic yum burger or this
the double yum burger
don't want a bun for your burger you say
jollibee has you covered they have
something called the burger steaks
patties of burgers smothered in their
mushroom gravy
you can get them in two patties three
patties
or the six patty family pack over here
the burger steaks only come as a
two-piece
in the u.s you can get a side of white
rice we only have one size
and there's this one right here same
here our rice just comes in one portion
and it's wrapped up like this
very cute largest thing on a u.s jelly
bean menu is this
the chicken joy bucket treat d
as in damn
i want to eat this all ten pieces of
chicken five sides and five of the peach
mango pies
all of this for a reasonable price of
thirty dollars
this is the biggest thing on a uk
jollibee menu it's a 12 piece family
feast and with one of these you get a 12
piece bucket of chicken joy
two sides of fries two chicken burgers
four chicken tenders
six dips and a 1.5 liter bottle of a
soda of your choosing
i actually want to start this section by
giving a shout out to jollibee their
nutritional information for the uk
wasn't publicly available when we were
looking but we asked them to share it
with us and they actually did
so gold star for you guys everyone else
take note the information
is publicly available in the u.s so no
special requests needed over here
we now know that an average three piece
from a uk jollibee assuming they give
you a drum
a thigh and a breast would come to 1059
calories i'd be lying if i said this was
good for you
the calories themselves aren't too bad
however there's just over 100 percent of
your daily sodium allowance in here as
well as around 80 percent of your daily
fat
a drum thigh and breast from a us
jollibee comes to 920 calories so our
chicken joy
actually has fewer calories than the uk
equivalent
as well as less than half the sodium
content in both countries there are some
differences in the nutritional stats
between the different cuts of chicken
for example a chicken joy thigh is the
most calorific cut whereas the chicken
joint breast is the highest in sodium
if you're looking to cut back on
calories ask them to only
give you drums three drums in the u.s
are around 660 calories
three thighs on the other hand will set
you back 1140
calories a 72 increase it's a similar
deal in the uk
three drumsticks would come to 777
calories
whereas three thighs would come to 1299
that's a 67 increase okay what about the
most calorific thing in the entire menu
that'd be this the spaghetti party pack
one of these
contains 5 000 calories as well as 10
000 milligrams of sodium
so therefore it is the most sodium-rific
thing
in the history of food wars
congratulations this
is designed to feed eight to ten people
yes but if there's anyone out there who
is eating one of these
on their own listen to me you gotta stop
over in the uk the highest calorie item
would obviously be the 12-piece bucket
now depending on the cuts of chicken you
get the calories in here could range
anywhere from 3060
to 5196. even if they maxed out the
calories and gave you all thighs in here
it would still somehow contain less
sodium than the spaghetti party pack
unfortunately jollibee in the uk does
not disclose its ingredients the only
thing we were able to find was an
allergen chart it's pretty comprehensive
but there's nothing too
shocking in there the only thing that
might surprise you is there's lots of
celery and mustard use across the
jollibee menu
same in the us the only ingredients info
we could find on this website
is that the mangoes and the peach mango
pies are made from
real philippine mangoes these mangoes
are incredibly sweet they're actually in
the guinness book of world records for
said sweetness plus
i joavella give them the award for fast
food dessert
excellence because these pies are the
best i love them so much
these things are so good looking over
the u.s allergen list it appears that
the burgers
at us jollibee have fish allergens in
them
now i don't know if that's something
with the meat or the sauces
perhaps cross contamination while being
prepared i have no idea
[Music]
here is everything you'll find on
jollibee's uk menu that you won't find
in the u.s
and here's everything at a u.s jollibee
you cannot get in the uk
let's start with some chicken now in the
uk we have an exclusive burger which is
the tropical chicken burger
it's a chicken burger which is served on
a brioche bun with cheese lettuce asian
ginger chili sauce and a ring of
pineapple as well
our next chicken option is this one the
asian chicken rice ball it's a bowl with
some chopped up chicken tenders some
rice
and an asian style slaw for our chicken
sandwiches we have the chicken sandwich
deluxe
generous of the mail jollibee your
chicken sandwich
is hovering around a mcchicken level
love the mcchicken but i wouldn't send
the mick chicken into a war
and certainly i would not send the uh
jellybean chicken sandwich deluxe
it's good it's not fantastic what i bet
is awesome though
is the spicy chicken sandwich yeah look
at that they got that they got the
sriracha on there you see that in the
bun
oh and jalapenos there okay
this is actually very good this might be
i might send this guy in the end of
battle
moving away from the chicken options we
have this which is the jolly hot dog
exclusive burgers we have the big yum
burger
and a personal favorite the aloha burger
it's got pineapple you see that
and underneath there
bacon i love it i love this burger i
think a bite
it's a fantastic burger highly recommend
it exclusive sides you can only get at
the u.s jollibee include
mashed potatoes i don't care
and the adobo rice this thing is a brick
of rice they are generous with the rice
man it's packed in there
the spices and a little bit of like meat
in here that's good yeah this would be a
good size it's a good call on this side
i like that a lot
everyone's favorite segment sauce talk
sauce
talk we have four sauces that you won't
find in the us and they are as follows
we have a buffalo sauce sriracha mayo
which in my opinion
is one of if not the best condiment then
we have a sweet chili sauce
and finally we have an asian ginger
chili sauce creamy sriracha
ranch i'm very fascinated with this a
pineapple barbecue i've never tried the
asian ginger chilli sauce before
oh i like it yeah that's good awesome
heat
whoa definitely hot you can see like
chili flakes kind of floating around in
there
that's not a red herring pineapple
barbecue
pineapple barbecue
that's fantastic barbecue sauce this
tastes a lot like
like a sweeter creamer version of
mcdonald's like standard barbecue sauce
if they sold this in retail i would
absolutely buy it that's very good
wow i love you jolly bean okay
jollibee has a few breakfast offerings
in um ginger chili sauce powerful two of
them jollibee in the uk has a few
breakfast options on offer we'll start
at this end with the breakfast burger
steak
next up we've got the breakfast chicken
joy our third option is the breakfast
hot dog but instead of the chicken or
the burger you can just get a hot dog on
the side and the last breakfast option
is a breakfast young burger
we have one exclusive drink in the uk
jollibee and it's this the pineapple
juice the color on this is like
darker than what i'm used to for
pineapple juice yeah just pineapple
juice
i like it a u.s exclusive that i wanted
to share with you guys was the jollibee
breakfast but as you can see i don't
have it according to the jollibee i went
to
about a month or two before filming this
jollibee decided to start
phasing out the breakfast because no one
was getting it now i don't know if
that's just the ones in this area
or nationally but for the most part i
think jollibee no longer has breakfast
so sorry guys and finally we have two
exclusive dessert options
here we have the mango coconut sundae as
well as a chocolate coconut sundae
the mango peach pies i cannot believe
you can't get these in the uk
that is a crime
might be the best fast food dessert yes
really
this is so great
see it's like i'm on my third bite it's
already gone these pies are incredible
you have to have one of these pies
and this delicious refreshing halo halo
this is so refreshing whatever they're
doing you're doing it well would you
like some
it's very good just blows kfc out the
water for me though